lascio
oggi challenge epica le freccette
decideranno cosa comprare sicuramente
avrete già visto questa challenge perché
super fa volta in youtube america la
stanno facendo tutti ma noi non
l'avevamo ancora fatta come funziona noi
tireremo le freccette e dove capiteranno
dovremo comprare qualcosa da quel
negozio in più le freccette ritireremo
anche per il nostro cagnolino merlino
sta qui che sta giocato con il suo è un
mio passo vi ricordate di questo l'avevo
detto nell'uovo di pasqua merlino
riuscito a prenderlo guardare ma ucciso
e distrutto quindi ormai è suo dovere
nel video dovete votare se vinco io o se
vince è vitale in base alle cose che ci
sono capitate le cose che abbiamo
comprata cielo poi sondaggio potrete
votare chi vince questa challenge
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere altre challenge
allora abbiamo la apple poi abbiamo
frutta e verdura ha capito e fatica
abiterà questo poi abbiamo un cagnolino
ma in questo caso e per merlino che sta
cercando di mangiarvi la mia già basta
barbera
poi abbiamo avatar
poi abbiamo una torta amiamo pasticceria
poi qua abbiamo tanti giocatori regali
quindi negozio di giocattoli piccolo
abbiamo altri giochi per cani quindi
sempre per fermi
per corretta rivedere cosa ci capiterà
iniziamo subito con il primo round che
vediamo chi inizia il primo turno carige
sasso carta forlì rilassate capitale
sono provvisori e vorresti che ti
capitasse di ore che mi capitasse a tiro
ma stavolta è il premio lino perché
parlino bisogno di regia di alcuni
giochi nuovi
io spero che ti capiti questo crediamo
quale di capitale per privato ad abitare
dovrà pescare ce ne sono sulle freccette
vediamo che cosa delicati da ok per il
ruolo che c'è perché ho preso dalla
bella passeggiata procede quindi devo
prendere o il cagnolino vedere clinica
il cagnolino
se si riesce ora devi tirare è
esattamente attaccato qua altrimenti il
tiro non ballo sono staccati allora
abbiamo fatto varie prove così vediamo
se riusciamo veramente beccarlo è questa
la distanza che deve prendere vediamo
perché niente tocca al mese amore preso
quello accaduto
ora tocca me adesso vediamo che
freccetta pascoe non perda e non perde
la merda mi fate la sfortuna non verde
gialla anch'io vediamo se riesco beccare
qualcosa allora io vorrei beccare
giocattoli giocato di più del risotto
si no crediamo difficili di moda allora
facciamo così avviciniamo lo un pochino
ricominciamo fresche ma sempre giallo è
giallo che ci porta sfortuna non
risolvere niente buy
agnolin al netto della prossima
sicuramente ci riuscirai meglio scott
per di non beccare giallo perché è
quello che porta sfortuna
[Musica]
ce la posso fare aspetto che c'è un
bambino che fa capolino caso mai privo
pronti nuovo popolo può peccato niente
affatto capitale del gioco è molto più
difficile di quanto ben fatti
difficilissimo ai propri occhi chiusi
verde porterà fortuna
lidia bai
e caduta però allora è coperto il
concetto che cielo marino alla sera
[Musica]
eccoci qua con berlino
stiamo andando
sto per dire negozi giocato lì no sei
giocatori per merlino stiamo andando
negozio di animali per prendere il
giochino berlino si contento berlino per
arriverà alle mozioni giocatori sono
sicura che sarà di giocattoli e ancora
ho detto gli animali sono sicura che
sarà felicissimo impazzita dalla gioia
perché lui lo adorerebbe con felice
felicissimo
possiamo videogiochi giocato abbiamo in
portali piazze fosse intesa la pallina
vediamo un bigliettino ma è troppo
piccolo tornaconto in luce la cosa un po
più gravi e mediamente più grande
cosa vuoi merita casa di non aver
partorito per piatto del programma
grazie poi toccato c'è cosa scegli come
gioco del cibo e pallino ma se leggiamo
bambini a questa qui
questi i suoi preferiti
[Musica]
stavo guardando tutto fosse roster
finora merlyn cosa scegli mi sa che
berlino pure proprio il cuscino quale fu
noi questo con le pecorelle abbiamo ma
insomma doveva segnare un gioco invece
proprio su un cuscino e questo vediamo
se su boccia che lascia lo dobbiamo
pagare prima sabato prossimo con le
pecorelle riuscito per ben tre ammannato
le pecore persona i panni fare tornati
verità ho fatto un pisolino
ed ecco qualcuno quindi ora glielo do
vediamo cosa fa perché un po stanco
quindi voglio vedere se si addormenta
sopra subito vediamo nel vino
vorreste grattando merlino che sento
[Musica]
lo statuto o dorando 6 giu nuovo gioco
insomma non è proprio il gioco lettino e
sdraio subito numer lino restante è
stanco bene sono proprio contenta che
essendo qualcosa e proprio gli piace il
si dormirà sopra e anche un po più
grandi di lui così durerà un pochino di
più va bene allora ti lascio in pace
continuiamo la nostra challenge che
tocca a me speriamo anch'io di beccare
qualcosa questa volta detto il giallo
porta sfortuna in questa giallo blu
vediamo
un partito si possono vedere le fragole
vitale contento che aprendo frutta e
verdura dai almeno mangiamo è però nel
zucchina le carote riguardate
giustamente della torta ci avevo puntato
alla po alla torta alla porta avevo
puntato alla torta la prova la porta a
strascico e francesca ieri l servirebbe
forse per vista valigia è capitata la
cosa più buona
la cosa più buona in realtà è la porta o
in questi ci si di buone le fragole ci
sono gli amici 10
allora che usiamo le pere andiamo le
pere anzitutto
prendiamo hdtv e inge mappe sono
tantissime anche le america j
aspetta che non scelgo un altro voglio
scegliere questo che fanno molto più
mature e noi per rendere anche le brave
persone
ma questo non melanzana
non è da recco che perdura e scegli il
peperone che ti piacciono tanto
un bel cavoletto più belle broccoletto
perché un drappo letto ci sta sempre
bene vado a prendere la mia freccetta
bene dovrei genere il verde funzione
questo challenge quindi spero finalmente
di peccare ma ricordo di che con me ha
funzionato mica con tre funzioni
giocattolino negozi di frutta e verdure
giocattoli che bello finalmente un
peccato qualcosa anch'io
cosa se no non lo so andiamo così
giocato decidiamo assieme ma che stiamo
negozi di giocattoli guerra se quel
pinguino
[Musica]
pizzica e più alto di me
non ci vuole tanto vero che cosa si
chiamò capannina raccolte qua
[Applauso]
[Musica]
che bello se non di cagnolini che
sembrano seri chissà come reagirà
ok ho sentito questa una mamma sono
state le gocce di giocattoli e non ho
preso questa palla ho preso una bambola
e poi ve la faccio vedere vi spiego il
perché ho preso una bambola in più ci
hanno dato questa palla che tipo una
palla piena d'aria
quindi non vedo l'ora di vedere merlino
come reagirà perché lui è abituato alle
palline piccole è una volta che gli darò
questa palla enorme voglio vedere quanto
tempo dura prima che la distrugga
provate a indovinare miei commenti
quanto tempo durera cinque minuti dieci
minuti un giorno una settimana vediamo
chi indovina riguardo le corse di
giocattoli ha scelto una bambola e di
rete ma per carità e sento una bambola è
una bambola interattiva la scelta perché
si state chiedendo a ogni giorno e in
centinaia di fare il video 24 ore da
genitori quindi faremo qui il video con
questa bambola interattiva perché questa
parla piange eccetera
ma chi è inquietante e riteniamo potessi
perché c'era un'altra bambola che si
chiamava l'uva bella con la barella che
era interattiva e tipo parlava diceva
più di 100 frasi muoveva la bocca però
poi abbiamo visto dei video della super
inquietante sembrava compissimo
espressione vera prova che sembrava viva
quindi abbiamo detto vabbè prendiamo
questa è una volta che facciamo il video
vedremo come se la caviamo 24 ore da
genitori russi caso ma poi come vi
dicevo in macchina sono andata dritta
altro anche una palla e ora vediamo se
berlino reagisce in qualche modo a
berlino da quando sta su questo cuscino
momento non se n'è neanche accorto con
dormendo lui berlino pubblico berlina
non ha fatto nessun effetto
così questa palla sic ed è scappato nel
4 tempo lo faremo perché tra l'altro
piena d'aria non è una palla normale che
un po spesso male piena d'aria anche
come berlino e pieno d'aria
era poco questa palla dai davvero sangue
lo per dire della velocità e bio fai
bene a maggio pensa che sia una pallina
piccola torino nella scuola e masticare
questa limitato di sta guardando con con
un area sprezzato ben berlino è
felicissimo devo dire oggi ha
conquistato due soci la palla e il
lettino contento nemmeno dai da allora
direi che si è svegliato berlino si
dovette all'indietro berlino avete posto
quell'orecchio non volevo di mangiarsi
la puzza troppo tardi ormai
poi si mette comodo lettino per la
richiesta va bene per lui è il paradiso
questo che chiamano pallina giganti come
sono nate le giganti il giardino
stefanino merlino gambe la non riesce
neanche a rosicchiano da parte grande
dame la donna da casa a bocca aperta
completamente valori già rodi chiarla
gallo presenterà questa palla per
fortuna c'è questa protezione che lui
sta rosicchiando altrimenti sarebbe già
rotta
berlino ha come si è spaventato è durata
cinque minuti quel papa per il trucco
così divertente potevamo passare assieme
gli strumenti affidati berlino chiunque
avesse detto che sarebbe durata cinque
minuti ha indovinato perché è durata
cinque minuti
lui si diverte lo stesso va bene la
lascerò così penserà che va da mordere e
che più contento adesso che prima si
caspita perché ora la può mordere bene
via si tratta di 30 teme lettino dove
andiamo
niente niente non la molla per mina mia
martini mi sono stancata gliele lascerò
così non lo so che fine fa ray mantilla
e blu come carlo rete
vediamo chi prova a puntare a
pasticceria va bene perché se volevi
quella legata una bella grande club
mi dispiace niente porta ci riprova dopo
[Musica]
qualcosa perché il bene sto portando
stato di fortuna stranamente è questo se
prendo qualcosa sarà l'ultimo turno mi
speriamo approcci io spero di prendere o
dei giochi per berlino o pasticceria
vediamo che deve comprendere un
presentavo però
cento
[Musica]
la coppia è tutto per me le verdure io
torno andiamo a prendere la cosa ciò che
stiamo andando infatti si e sceglierò
tutto io devo mangiare qualcosa il
cattivo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ecco qua il mio bottino dalla
pasticceria e tuttavia dura la vuoi
mangiare dopo vi faccio vedere cosa ho
preso ogni anno direi che il berlino è
davvero felicissimo con il letto che
assetto guardate come si è messo berlino
sta il proprio comodo è malatesta
dovrebbe metterla dentro
berlino
ai poteri grande che hai che è
innanzitutto apriamo i nostri dolci
perché non vedo l'ora di apprezzarli
allora sono curiosa di assaggiare questo
ti ricordi come si chiamava cartucce ha
detto cartucce ha capito che non è il
patto c'è un gatto nel frattempo di
contare i giorni che salutare tutti ciao
ciao
allora facciamo una di queste
sembra quasi spagna non lo troviamo a
saperlo sempre a torto che muore non
sono morto
ora voglio assaggiare questo questo che
cosa sono noccioline natolini ricoperti
di cioccolato fondente
proviamo
[Musica]
pratico lo smit ormai un po mese perché
lo zenit era pieno di caramello zucchero
ne sa qualcosa e questo è un po più
leggero che trova di tutto
abbiamo il signor merlino si sta
chiudendo il suo cuscino luogo però come
al solito lui dorme sempre di traverso
non ce l'ha fatta 2003 il suo nuovo
cuscino infine voglia di salutare tutti
dove basta agli rischio tutto non me li
mangio a tutti ma dopo tutti noi andiamo
lì prima che berlino vitali ritrovino mi
devo nascosto girati dall'altra parte
non devi vedere doveri nascondo quello
che è stato più fortunato in questa
challenge decisamente il mattino che sta
continuando a giocare con la palla
distrutta che dura da cinque minuti ma
anch'io devo perché ho mangiato un po
dei due dolci vero demonio non tornerà
votate chi vince secondo voi basta alle
cose che abbiamo comprato chi vince
quali sono le cose che mi sono piaciute
di più
berlino la palla ai desini commenti che
altri challenge volete che facciamo
scrivere che si presenta ma voglio di
più li lasceremo un cuoricino e andremo
a farle siamo andati a sentire la sigla
della serie ufficiale animata alita
store e xvi lascia la cartellina qua e
poi rilasciate tra i capelli né su cui
cliccare per vedere
altri altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione ciao
[Musica]
nel cielo una terra lontana
perché
[Musica]